what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i got a
special guest on the channel sorry
garvey sauragi i'm here i'm back again
you're gonna be seeing my face on a
regular basis just get used to it yeah
yeah so today um we are reacting to
jordan peterson versus michael dyson
michael dyson yeah about racism about
racism oh wait guys before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell like the video
and we just started membership so sign
up for a membership for exclusive behind
the scenes content and go subscribe to
sara's page go subscribe to my page i've
got content too he humbles women
i try
nice some women won't be humble they are
just unruly
okay jordan peterson versus michael
dyson
good point jordan let's have you jump in
on this idea of what you see is the
pernicious danger of group think when it
comes to ethnicity
uh when it comes to gender why do you
think that that's one of the primal sins
in your view of quote political
correctness
well i think it's one of the primal sins
of identity politics players on the left
and the right just to be clear about
that
personally since this has got personal
at times i'm no fan of the identitarian
right i think that anybody who plays a
game a conceptual game where group
identity comes first and foremost risks
an exacerbation of tribalism it doesn't
matter whether it's on the left to the
right
with regards to the idea of group rights
well there's a fundamental and this is
something we fall into terribly in
canada not least because we had to
contend with the threat of quebec
separatism but
the idea of group rights is
extraordinarily problematic because
the
the the obverse of the coin of
individual rights is individual
responsibilities and you can hold an
individual responsible and an individual
can be responsible
and so that's partly why individuals
have rights
but groups
how do you hold a group responsible
i mean the whole idea is not it's not a
good idea to hold a group responsible
first of all it flies in the face of the
idea of the sort of justice systems that
we've laid out in the west that are
essentially predicated first on the
assumptions you know what
you know what that is to me right
and i'm just gonna say it i think
there are certain groups of people
that
if someone individual does something a
whole group gets categorized about it
yeah do you know what i mean so we say
if a black person does something if a
mexican person does something or if an
arab person does something right the
group get look gets looked at like
oh like those people are crazy however i
think
and a lot of white people i think don't
have this
they don't know that a white person can
do something individually and they don't
get seen the same way
by the other groups so like white people
so like black people
mexicans arabs
don't necessarily tend to look up all
white people a certain way if a white
person does something really what do you
think i think that's wrong all right go
on tell me why because i always hear
like white people that's what they
always say like oh white people or oh
like
you're so white i hear that all the time
and i also hear when there's a mass
shooting that's always their first
response says oh was the shooter white
so the thing is i think
i think it also has to do with i'm not
saying you're wrong right yeah i'm
saying i think it also has to do with
influence and power okay
because
i think
certain groups of people have more
influence and power so for instance
black people don't run media stations
generally so they can't
show a constant barrage
of like crazy white people look
they're crazy
do you know what i mean however like
media stations
can do that and a lot of the times do
portray a certain image of black people
anal mexicans and other arabs
i don't know i
i feel like the media is always talking
about white people too
i mean like because i always hear in the
media like like i think i feel like
that's the group that i always hear
about it's like because like the phrase
is like oh white people oh the white
like
the one percent the white men
i mean
i hear that yeah
i just think
but i just don't really look at people
in that way like i just feel like it's
kind of silly to group people by
race when there's so many different but
the thing is that's what this is the
thing obviously that's what see i'm a
black male right so yeah my experience
you're a white woman right you will have
different experiences within the world
right so
my experience knowing who i am
i know i'm not a criminal you know i've
been in prison i've been to jail
never sold drugs
but i know that
there is a perception
of black males okay
by the general society it's not just
white people okay because we get we get
we internalize it too okay sometimes
within the black community do you know
what i'm saying so we feel like a black
guy's gotta know how to play basketball
or he's gotta know how to dance so he's
gotta know how to do something it's like
we don't all do that yeah
well i mean the other stereotypes you
know what i mean like it's a stereotype
yeah so
i think yeah i just think i think we
should continue i think yeah i wanna
hear i wanna hear some more of
individual innocence but also on the
possibility of individual guilt not
group guilt
we saw what happened in the 20th century
many many times when the idea of group
guilt was it was it it was unable to get
a foothold let's say in the polity and
in the justice system it was absolutely
catastrophic and so okay fine group
rights well what are you going to how
are you going to contend with the
alternative to that the opposite of that
that where's the group responsibility
how are you going to keep how are you
going to hold your groups responsible
well we don't have to talk about that
because we're too concerned with
rectifying hypothetical
rectifying historical injustices
hypothetical and otherwise and that's
certainly not to say that there weren't
any shortage of absolutely catastrophic
historical injustices that's not the
point the point is
how you so pearl do you think right what
you just said there do you think that
historical catastrophes must be
compensated for no no that's stupid
so then
i'm not saying i'm not agreeing or
disagree yeah so then how come
there were groups of people that got
confrontation then
okay for instance like jewish people
chinese japanese people with the with
the with the bombs like there were
groups of people who got compensated i
don't know
so it wasn't fair
what well i'm talking about like what i
what i think about group i think about
reparations
so i don't i mean maybe if if the people
were still alive today like i don't know
maybe
but
like when when you said historical i
thought you meant like at the past
present yeah so like in the past
people talk about slavery so in the past
you know the holocaust happened in the
past you know yeah japanese but people
got compensated for it yeah do you know
what i mean and this thing actually one
of the things i think i think it's a
double-edged sword with a lot of black
people actually because you can double
us between victimhood and not and it's
like it's like give us our money it's
like
first of all i don't think reparations
is viable
first of all um i don't think any
country is going to [ __ ] their
economy for a bunch of people
i just don't believe that it's going to
happen
um however do i think
given the um
[Music]
there's a book right called how the how
europe underdeveloped africa
and when you read that book you realize
that the whole industrial revolution and
stuff like that was started because of
the colonization and you just think
well if you didn't if you didn't do that
then you wouldn't be as successful
so what do you mean by the colonization
so the colonization of africa so
both the people
and the resources right
there's a direct correlation between the
colonization of africa and the
industrial revolution okay and so with
all the metals and
the rubber and all this kind of stuff
coming from africa okay it fueled the
industrial revolution of the west
wait so or you're saying like in africa
when you say colonized you're saying
like like did england come in and in
colorado yeah like so european france
spain portugal england and they like
enslaved africans and then yes that's
okay so they
well they they enslaved at least
colonize the
continent okay
so when you colonize a continent and
then you take
then you take ownership of the resources
you're able to gather those resources
together and use them to your own
benefit right and so you gather those
resources using your own benefit and
build up your economy right all the
while
messing up the economy of that actual
country right and so it's like
well would the west have been
as successful
well the problem is slavery happened
everywhere so you you could make that
argument with like everywhere across
history like arabs they're the worst
arabs
are the first to save african people you
know they they castrated they castrated
yeah
and they still do it to this day and oh
shoot sorry and um like the irish their
indentured sir france had a lower life
expectancy than slaves
yes and i hear people say that and i do
not disagree but
economies weren't made off of irish
um indentures i just don't know what
you'd like do about it today
like well that's why i said because it's
not it's not something that
can be quote unquote rectifiers i think
the way in which to rectify it
personally
is for black people to say okay cool
it's time for us to take control of our
own
resources
oh so like just individualized thinking
oh no or just
self-determination oh yeah like everyone
needs to determine themselves oh okay do
you know what i mean i don't think like
asking for something that you're never
gonna get is yeah or but i don't even
think that would make sense if you were
like like if you're gonna take money
from people that didn't do it and give
it to people that weren't alive for it
you know whatever you yeah but the thing
is i i get that but that's the thing
it's like
the the economy that we have today
yeah it's built off of it yeah do you
know what i mean so
this is the thing like people keep
saying well if your economy was built
off of it then there must be something
and i get the concept
if you if you live in this house
but your grandparents stole it off of my
grandparents yeah right yeah and then
this house is now a mansion
yeah and then my grandchildren turn up
to your house like stop this is your
house you're gonna be like
uh well it happened right you know i
made it happen but right well but then
and the other issue is like
like it wasn't
like um like black people enslaved black
people too
so you don't say like a third out of
freed slaves in louisiana on slaves
was organized by
europeans
no that's
not the ones that like captured them no
no because
there were many africans involved the
europeans couldn't survive in africa
they would get malaria yeah so they used
to use the african jews to go and get
them yeah and bring them yeah totally
agree yeah so it's like how would you
no that's what i'm saying
but i totally agree like you're always
going to get
people that are freaking traitors and i
don't know like people that you can pay
to do a job for you because but this is
what i'm saying it's like
i get the i what i'm saying is i get the
argument of
you i want that back i'm not saying
you're gonna get it back though yeah i'm
just saying i get the argument
no i don't get it you don't get it
i mean maybe they'll probably say it's
cause i'm white so you don't get the
argument of well i'm just like my
parents like i have one grandparent from
lithuania or great grandparent from like
lithuania i'm like lithuanian polish
german and irish oh so you're white
white yeah yeah
like but you're like white one yeah but
i just don't like
like i'm just not that
into those cultures because i'm american
and so i just don't
really
know or care what happened back then
because i'm alive today no i get that
but the thing is
yeah i get it but i get what you're
saying but i think
if you take something from someone
and it's people have witnessed it yeah
and then they've seen you take that
money and build a whole empire with the
money that you stole yeah they're
they're what you their children are
gonna be like yo that's my father's
stuff yeah i mean i can make that
argument if it's like you're the person
that did it but like their grandkids
like what they didn't do anything
no they didn't yeah they didn't you
didn't do anything so that's what i'm
saying is it's not
realistic to expect them to give it back
right and you know what i'm saying it's
not realistic because they're gonna be
like well i didn't do it yeah but i
think the thing is is that
black because i've heard this argument
so many times a black person i think
black people understand
how
the west was grown
what um what percentage of white people
in the us do you think owned slaves
probably less than five percent probably
um less than one percent less than one
percent yeah it was like it was i don't
remember what the exact stat was but it
was like five percent like back then of
the south yeah so and like most people
in the us immigrated after
so
because it was a slave owners
with the plantations because those
plantations were huge and those
plantations aren't owned by your average
white person no
get it no
okay let's view the situation at the
most fundamental level and group rights
are an absolute catastrophe in my
opinion well let's michelle come in on
that point
um the reason
the reason that trump and brexit in
britain and all kinds of nativists all
over europe are succeeding is not the
triumph of the right it's the
catastrophic failure of the left it's
our fault
we
absolutely
[Music]
my point is not that i've turned to the
right or anything like that or that i'm
nice and fluffy and want everybody to be
decent i'm saying [ __ ] political
correctness resist
fight if you have a point of view fight
it in the proper manner using
democracies it should be not channels of
education not language
you know it's so silly
but there's a chess rule you know in
chess the best move to play in chess is
not the best chess move it's the move
your opponent least wants you to play at
the moment you're being recruiting
sergeants for the right but by annoying
and upsetting and instead of fighting
either fighting or persuading but
political correctness is a middle course
that simply doesn't work well first of
all you said be empirical now empirical
as far as i know the word means that
which can be verified or falsified
through the census exactly so if we look
at it in an objective um a way
the reality is that people don't have
equal access to the means to articulate
the very moment you're talking i'm
talking about the empirical results of
this political attitude i understand
that but my point is simply this i'm
suggesting to you that people use the
weapons at hand
now it was abraham joshua heschel the
rabbi who said everybody's not guilty
but everybody's responsible
right that's a distinction there
everybody clearly is not guilty but
what's interesting look at the flip side
if you have benefited from
300 years of holding people in servitude
thinking that you did it all on your own
why can't these people work harder let
me see for 300 years you ain't had no
job
so the reality is for 300 years you hold
people in the bands you hold them in
subordination you refuse to give them
rights then all of a sudden you free
them and say you're now individuals not
having the skills not having their own
let me not having to feel recent i'm
talking about america first of all i'm
some of the american society first of
all i'm talking about the northern
hemisphere i'm talking about every
society where enslavement has existed
but i'm speaking specifically of the
repudiation of individual rights among
people of color in america who were
denied the opportunity to be individuals
so i see i obviously and ideally close
that a second do you absolutely
do you think there's slavery in america
or do you think the racism problem
in america is different in that europe
because you're from america i'm not
racist you know i know people are i
don't really
i don't see much racism in america and i
know people i know they're going to say
that's like because i'm white or
whatever but i'm like you too white to
see it but i just
i don't like where i'm from like
everyone's pretty nice
like i'm from huntley
i have no idea
yeah it's like a it's like a suburb of
chicago right so
because that's the thing i think
sometimes like
black people and
black people in america
a lot of the time in my experience they
see
racism differently from people in europe
they were not in america oh yeah that's
true actually do you know what i mean
yeah it's because of
um
well
say it well
no it's because i this is have you ever
read this book uh it's on my show if i
haven't read it so it's it talks about
when race relations are the worst okay
and in the u.s basically
the book oh yeah yeah sorry guys um and
it's um thomas so black red next right
white liberals and it talks about like
when ra it when race relations are like
the worst in the u.s it comes from
um the culture like like black culture
in the u.s and when i think of i don't
even like saying black culture because
it's really not black culture because it
comes from east england and basically
east england like it was the slave
owners and the annabelle himself
and in the antebellum south like
basically it was a lot of the dialects
like you was you'd be like like kind of
the dialects that you hear in like rap
culture yeah yeah so that culture um it
was from the slave owners from east
england and it was in the antebellum
cell right and
nine out of every 10 black people back
then had that culture
and one out of every three white people
did and a lot of the yeah yeah so so um
a lot of the
really poor times when the race
relations were really bad it was when a
group of people from the south came to
the north but you can see um
you could see the the um
the like they would they would say the
same things about the white people that
emigrated like the same way they would
describe like black people back then was
the same way they described white people
and that's why you'd see things like
irish need not apply because yeah it was
that culture in the uk they had no
blacks no irish no dogs
oh okay
they're signs
and basically that culture is like
extremely unproductive it's like um they
had
i want to say
67 of the dairy cows
were in the antebellum south but they
only made like eight percent of the
dairy
why because it's just a very
unproductive cult it's like it's i don't
want to say black culture because it's
really not it's like
it's like the rap culture that you see
where it's like an emphasis on religion
but it's like
but it's not really yeah you want to
take like energy they want to thank god
for everything but they're doing all
kinds of craziness
and you would the the number one way
people died in the south was someone
looked at them weird and a sign of
disrespect
and what what yeah what yeah was this
it's
i was just reading this the other day
but um
i don't know but if you if literally
it's like this part of the book right
where it talks about they call it the
so when you say people died what people
that black people did
oh both black white it was it was one
out of ever it was people with the
annabellum south culture that came from
east england right
okay i didn't know that and so the
reason i think that it's like a little
bit different is because like more
people black and white people have that
culture in the u.s
like and that's why i think it's
different because the culture died out
mostly in england
so that's why you think like racism is
different in like europe than it is
america in america i think it is in
america because i think it's a little
bit like worse i would say in america
but i don't really think it's race as
much as that culture i think people
discriminate against that culture which
is like rap culture
all right so do you think because rap
culture is such a big culture now
that
black people
because i know i'm a black man yeah
people have assumed i can rap yeah yeah
i can't rap for [ __ ] right i can brother
you probably write better than me
but it's like because the culture has
been um exported
and it's been seen as a norm yeah that's
what i made a video called i'm sick of
the black community right yeah and one
of the things that i said is that our
underbelly
has become our upper echelon
as black people it's like
we don't
glorify
the things that we should be glorifying
we glorify the underbelly so i know that
as a black man someone said to me oh
yeah you must know do you know someone
that sells drugs no
yeah
but you assume so because the culture
has been exported so cleverly that you
think that i'm like that well
i i find it's different in europe
because
like at nigeria like when i feed people
from like like africa nigeria they don't
have that culture they really don't they
don't talk about racism everywhere well
you can't voice black continents like
where's the racism is that we're all
black no i mean like the ones from that
i meet that are like from like that came
here
do you know why because well i said my
family are from the caribbean right yeah
so
our thing is okay so when you're in
africa or in your caribbean
your whole thing is if you go to england
or america or wherever
you work your hardest
because you've got people back home that
you need to feed right so
black people that come from outside of
america
to the west or to america have a
different mindset
and they say i'm just here to get it
done
get work done do my thing send money
back home nigerian americans outpace
whites so do indian americans yeah
because nigerians have a they have a
hustle mentality yeah i'm around a lot
of nigerians but that's that's why i
think it's like not so much race it's
that culture i think people discriminate
against that culture
and like and so in the 60s when race
relations were really bad the race so
the way they would measure race
relations is like one interracial
marriages and two
um
i can't remember the second way but it
was like a seemingly like credible way
and basically race relations were
getting better up until like the 40s and
50s and then the 60s there was a huge
mass of people that came from the south
the antebellum cell that came into the
cities right and so then that's when you
started to see like black only white
only areas which i'm not like that's
totally wrong but but i i think they
were more discriminating against the
culture because if you look at you don't
think that you don't think it was a
racing i you think it was a culture
thing i think it was
more of a culture thing than a race
thing because if you look at the one out
of ten white black people that derived
that didn't come from that culture that
were raised up in like the christian
schools in the north
um
they they economic they were
economically outpacing whites
yeah but i think i would i'm not going
to disagree with you but i think the
thing is is that what it
i think when it comes to racism this is
one of the things i say a lot of the
things that aren't spoken about is the
subconscious mind of people because we
all have biases you can all say that we
have biases right and so we don't know
when biases
are being used or not being used so when
you talk about that like
if you've come from a culture for the
last couple of hundred years that
generally sees black people as slaves
generally
don't you think that bias towards black
people being quote unquote less than
would have influenced them
when it came time for them to come in
well sort of but like half the
population was the north and they were
fighting to free slaves
and then how would you how would that
make sense with like the one out of
every three black people in louisiana
owned slaves
and there was like a lot of people a lot
of them because you export the culture
if you export the culture of
black peoples are slaves yeah if you
export that psychology
it's gonna permanently just like would
you say that like black people are also
prejudiced against like black people of
course okay so okay so you think it's
like the same yeah because if you like i
said that's why black people can come up
to me and white people come up to me and
ask me the same question yeah because
the culture has been exported yeah so
cleverly that even black people think of
themselves in this way
and so and so if they're going to think
of if we're going to think of ourselves
in this way
that means
of course general society is going to
think of do you know i mean black people
in a certain way because it's because
the culture
has been exported but i just when you're
talking about general society like it
comes down to individuals and i just
don't see a lot of individuals like
like really heavily discriminating
i don't either yeah like for even me
like i think every person i've hired has
been black
and it's not like i was you know it's
just the people that showed up and
wanted to do the job
and
like i just don't see that that much on
like an individual basis but then that's
the thing i was
asking about europe and america is it
different
because in
because the way in which
i think black americans people in
america
generally tend to think in in my
personal point of view in very victim
yeah backstage but it goes back to like
i think it's the culture i think the
victim status being a victim is a
culture yeah it was part of the
annabelle himself
it was part of like that culture because
again remember nine out of every ten
black people derived from that culture
in the south one out of every three
white people and there's like an account
in indiana where they're describing like
the whites that came from the south in
indiana it was very similar to the ways
that they would describe the blacks that
came into the cities right okay so
that's why i think people discriminate
against the culture
and it's just so happy i think race does
have a factor though sure yeah i think
it doesn't matter yeah i'm not gonna say
because it's like would you prefer to be
next door to
black people who have a certain culture
or black people who don't have a certain
culture so question do you feel like
indian like like um people from india
are discriminated against in the same
way because it's like there's i know
indeed like indians that are darker than
you yeah but indians like i said indians
have a different
mindset yeah so it's the culture so
their culture is to work but that
doesn't mean that there's no
discrimination it just means that it's
like it's like me
if i find somebody's being racist
towards me i can either say
oh my god you're a racist old you know
what i've still got stuff to do yeah i i
i haven't got time for that yeah do you
know what i mean i haven't got time you
just you asked if i thought it was more
like the race or the culture and i'm
saying like i think it's the culture
because if it was the race then i think
indians would have the same like
problems and they don't
like it well in the uk in the uk and in
america because i'm american so you're
british i don't know yeah it might be
different yeah but yeah it's interesting
we can get that yeah you should you
should read that book it seriously like
changed my view on a lot of things
because but then is it america specific
yes yes well no actually no it talks
about slavery around the world right
okay it's it's it's written for
americans but it's very
it talks about like like slavery on a
global perspective
because that's what i think people
generally to understand that
black people have different experiences
in different places also
whereas
whereas i think black americans sorry i
don't want to like
upset you guys but i think black
americans tend to think that they can
monopolize a quote-unquote black
experience
oh oh yeah do you know what i mean it's
like black people i'm i'm from the uk
i'm black yeah my experiences is not
going to be the same as yours in america
and i think michelle goldberg does too
agree with the emphasis on individuals
what we're saying to you is that we have
not been permitted to be individuals we
have not been permitted to exercise our
individual autonomy and authority and
the refusal to do so to recognize me as
an individual means when you roll up on
me and i'm a 12 year old boy in a park
and you shoot first
in ways you do to black kids that you
don't do to white kids you are not
treating that person as an individual if
we're living in a society where women
are subject to aberrant forms of horrid
uh patriarchal sexist and misogynist
behavior you are not acknowledging the
centrality of the individuality of women
you are treating them according to a
group dynamic and if we if we get beyond
the ability of people on the right to to
understand the degree to which they have
operated from the basis of benefit from
group identity without having said i am
by saying this the great american
philosopher knows
said that it has been said that racism
is so american that if you challenge
racism you look like you're challenging
america we are challenging inequality we
are challenging the refusal to see me as
an individual when we overcome that have
at it we're all money going
so you know i think it's good this is
good
it's getting stirred here so it's got a
couple of questions so let's
let's your site
let's assume for a moment that i've
benefited from my white privilege
okay so let's assume that that's fine
yeah well that's what you would say
so um um so let's say here let's get
precise about this okay was that in the
very individual of you
let's get precise about this okay let's
get president to what degree is my
present level of attainment or
achievement
a consequence of my white privilege and
i don't mean sort of i mean do you mean
five percent do you mean 15
do you mean 25
do you mean 75
and what do you propose i do about it
how about a tax
how about a tax that's like specialized
for me so that i can account for my damn
privilege so that i created
about it
now let's get precise about one other
thing okay we'll get precise about one
other thing
precise yeah precisely yes and so
if
if we can agree and we haven't that the
left can go too far which it clearly
can't then how would my worthy opponents
precisely define when the left that they
stand for has gone too far you didn't
like equity equality of outcome i think
that's a great marker but if you have a
better suggestion and and won't sidestep
the question so let's figure out how i
can dispense with my white privilege and
so that you can tell me when the left
has gone too far since they clearly can
and that's what this debate is about
about political correctness it's about
the left going too far and i think it's
gone too far in many ways and i'd like
to figure out exactly how and when so
the reasonable left could make its
ascendance again and we could quit all
this nonsense
[Applause]
[Music]
mike i want to come to you on those
great michelle on jordan's point about
how does he
in a sense who's talking for a minute
wow i think he talked for like three
minutes straight
um
yeah i don't think jordan peterson is
going to have a problem getting anything
that he wants
i don't think he has a problem um but
then equally i don't think michael dyson
would have had a problem or has a
problem now be him being on the stage do
you get what i'm saying i think he's
probably speaking for
people that aren't him mm-hmm do you
know what i mean
he's
speaking for people that aren't him and
that whole equality of
opportunity opportunity versus a quality
of outcome thing
like
okay i've said this many times like
if you go around the world even in
america
black peop the people that they call
black people occupy the bottom of
most social economic ladders
whether it be in america i'm talking
about the general public
they occupy the bottom of the social
economic ladder
so black people will
uh be the poorest
generally depending on where you go
um they will have
nigerians
know what i'm saying if in nigeria
if another group of people move in
they tend to push
black peoples down for instance it
happened with this one of the things
that idiot mean was upset about original
idiot i mean that was u.s
nigerians are they they're either equal
or they outpace whites in the u.s no but
i'm saying i'm talking about when you're
in your respective countries oh so for
instance if
ghanaians are in ghana obviously it's a
ghanaian country but if another group of
people are moving into god so the
chinese are moving into ghana right now
and
their social economic status
is actually higher than ghanaians
because they get into the meetings they
get seen because they work for i don't
know corporate companies etc etc so i
just i've always said that if black
people generally tend to occupy the
bottom of the social economic ladder and
i know it's something that sounds
controversial now the only thing we are
going to have to do is
determine ourselves
do you know what i mean like if there's
a
if there's a pattern yeah we can't rely
on anybody by ourselves to get ourselves
out of the situation that we're in and
and that's one of the things that i
think
like people have been saying to black
people just get on with it do the job
and you get and i think i tell black
people that too i'm like all right cool
we find ourselves in a position what we
can do about it
walk scream cry yeah do you know i mean
march yeah
well i just i think it's like a
mentality i don't know like i think i
think that mentality you're talking
about is just like there's certain
people that it doesn't matter like i
feel like you if i placed you in a state
where you didn't know anybody like you
would figure something out
yeah yeah you would figure out how to
get a job and yeah you'd figure it out
yeah yeah and it's just like
because i have yeah because i may have
different mentality i've always said
it's like being in a rainforest and if
somebody drops you in a rainforest
it doesn't matter what you think
the snakes are there the frogs are there
the jaguars are there if you stay there
crying for too long
the rainforest will eat you up yeah
right yeah that's a good announcement it
will eat you up yeah if you say okay
cool let me learn the jaguar let me
learn the snake let me learn the
environment you'll survive and i feel
like i'm one of those people i'd be like
you know what forget the crying i need
to survive and i need to get things done
so but a lot of people do they stay
crying in the environment get an equal
voice in this debate back if it is
implied that his participation brings
with it this baggage of white privilege
that doesn't allow him to see clearly
the issues that are before us but that
is to be complicit in the very problem
itself terminologically you're beginning
at a point that's already
productive and controversial you're
saying how can he get his equality back
who are you talking about
jordan peterson trending number one on
twitter
jordan peterson with an international
international bestseller i want him to
tweet something out about me and my book
jordan peterson right this is what i'm
saying to you why the rage bruh
you you're doing well but you're a mean
mad white man
and you're gonna get us right
and well i'm saying that's true like he
knows him
that's true
i don't know he's a mean white man
though like what the hell
jordan peterson is so nice too
and what i'm saying to you empirically
and precisely when you ask the question
about white privilege the fact that you
asking and the way you oh my gosh
whoa what the hell what the hell was
that
the mean man was not excavating
about hey it's like bro just say what
you're saying like why wouldn't that
that's when you know someone has a bad
argument when they use these big words
for no reason just like for don't just
explain yourself like
they try to they try to help smarter
than they are you know what i mean yeah
i've had it trust me i've had it it's
about the degree to which we are willing
as a society
what's interesting to me you're talking
about not having a collective identity
what do you call a nation
are you canadian are you canadian by
yourself
are you an individual oh all right so
now he's just getting personal see i
always say that you lose you lose the
argument when you start getting personal
you do you do because it means you don't
have the fast things no statistics to
win
see if i if me and you are having a
conversation like yeah but look at your
dress this
why this is fine
your dress is fine
by the way but i'm just saying if i go
to something then it's just like yeah
i've lost the argument yeah i agree
so do most conservatives yeah you're
talking about not having a collective
identity what do you call a nation
are you canadian are you canadian by
yourself
are you an individual or are you part of
a group when america formed its union
it did so in opposition to another group
so the reality is is that those who are
part of group identities and politics
deny the legitimacy and validity of
those groups
and the fact that they have been created
thusly and then have resentment against
others all i'm asking for is the
opportunity the the the quotation you
talk about the difference between a
quality of outcome and equality of
opportunity that's a staid and retry
argument hack need phrase derived from
the halcyon days of the debate over
affirmative action are you looking for
outcomes that can be determined equally
or are you looking for opportunity if
you that's true you can just say
someone's a mean man doesn't have to be
a mean black man or a mean white man
no i agree i i think that's
i kind of
i kind of well the debate is about
racism so it's going to get dragged in
so that's what they always do to me when
they're losing the argument about gender
because i don't really argue race too
much on my show like if i argue stuff
it's usually more gender based right and
whenever
the girls that i'm arguing against are
losing the conversation like when i when
i argue against feminism they'll just go
to well you're a white woman and i'm
just like
it's the go-to isn't it i'm just like
could you could you offer me something
of substance like an argument not just i
mean yeah i'm pretty pale
yeah we also have to understand that
most people have been taught
that debate
is wrong
so it's like oh if you haven't if you've
got a bad opinion just keep it to
yourself yeah that's what we've been
talking well and if and if i'm wrong
like if i'm wrong or they're wrong like
you should want to debate ideas like you
learn a lot like my opinions have
changed on certain things because of
debates i've had so am i yeah and it's
like if nobody talks to each other we're
afraid of like offending the other
person like we can't get to the truth
you have to you have to be willing to
risk offending people yeah even this
video here is probably gonna offend some
people do you know what i mean it will
but you have to be able to risk
offending people yeah no one of our
great presidents said if you start a man
in a race a hundred years behind it is
awfully difficult to catch up so i don't
think jordan peterson is suffering from
anything except an exaggerated sense of
entitlement and resentment and his own
privilege is invisible to him and it's
manifest with lethal intensity and
ferocity right here on stage
jordan i'm gonna have to let you respond
to that
[Music]
well
what i derived from that
series of rebuttals let's say is twofold
the first is that
saying that the radical left goes too
far when they engage in violence is not
a sufficient response by any stretch of
the imagination because there are sets
of ideas in radical leftist thinking
that led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea not at the level of violent action
it's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence it's like being
against poverty it's like you know
generically speaking decent people are
against
poverty and violence doesn't address the
issue in the least
and with regards to my privilege or lack
thereof i mean i'm not making the case
that i haven't had advantages in my life
and disadvantages in my life like most
people you don't know anything about my
background or where i came from it
doesn't matter to you because
fundamentally i'm a mean white man
that's a hell of a thing to say in a
debate
[Applause]
[Music]
let me let me just say very very brief
because i want to move on to men and
women
the mean mad white comment was not
a historical excavation of your past
it's based upon the evident vitriol with
which you speak in the denial of a sense
of equanimity among combatants in an
argument so i'm saying again you're a
mean mad white man and the viciousness
is evident okay
so i have a question do you think
there's money in racism there's money in
everything no capitalism sometimes i
think these people shoot
like sometimes i think these people
like him like i don't i don't know him i
like race hustlers yeah like they almost
do it for because okay for example
me i know if you say certain words on
the channel you get more views
there's like a particular audience like
like because i used to post more like
random stuff and my channel started to
blow up when i like stopped doing that
right and it was more talking about like
the problems of men and and there are a
lot of problems again and like stuff
that i really advocate for but sometimes
i think there are people that milk a
problem in order to make money off of
course that's what blm done yeah
that's what bm done it's like
racism sells to a particular demographic
just like feminism so particularly
like
you just gotta
understand your audience and i really do
think like a lot of these people just
understand they understand what they
want to hear yeah do you know what i
mean it's like if you put us in the
in the category of victims
we'll give you the money no that's what
and the more i get into media the more i
see it because there's some stats that
there's no way these people like don't
know um so i'm not media people
okay like for example this this is more
of a feminism one but i'm sure there's
examples with race hustlers too but the
one i'm thinking of is the one in three
women where victims of a sexual assault
are great yeah and like that's not true
it's not even close i've had that
statistic yeah a long time yeah and it's
not true and there's no way they don't
know that it's not true because
why is it because because they included
people that like if if i hooked up with
someone and i was drunk and he was drunk
they included that
oh
wow and what percentage of hookups are
when both the people are drunk
a freaking high-ass percent i would
guess at least one in three
right
and like there's other research that
have said like most people most people
whenever having some kind of yeah that's
what like alcohol or whatever you do
most of one night stands and like um
casual hookups for the first time are
drunk
and so you're going to tell women that
we're victims in college if we were too
drunk what if i got too drunk and robbed
someone
no you got to prison yeah and so it's
like why is this like
just because he could be drunk too
and so they they encountered that they
also counted like if someone grabbed
your butt
which okay that's not i don't like that
but that's happened to me i'm not
scarred
like random people you know you know
like creepy ass guy like creepy guys i
get it that's weird that's violent but
i'm not i've had my ass crap yeah like
you're not being about crying over it
like it's like oh that was weird but
then you just keep moving yeah or
getting cat called they they include
like all this stuff
but then that is assuming that women and
men think the same though
about that well i'm a woman and i'm
telling you like it is not i mean it's i
don't appreciate that but like it's you
should like you can't tell you can't
include that in one those statistics
though
that's what i'm saying yeah you can't
include that so they're clearly hustling
that because there's no way you're that
big and putting that in that big of a
platform
and not knowing that that's false same
with the wage gap why do they keep
pushing this this wage gap that doesn't
exist
like they have to know and i just i see
this and
with certain people when they like talk
like this it's just usually because they
don't have facts data or statistics to
back up their argument yeah i think
racehorses exist not really do you yeah
and i think um
is that like i said does racism exist do
racist racist people exist yes yes of
course yes
but to hustle it especially the way in
the way blm done it yeah like they out
hustled the black community with me by
millions do you know what i mean and
it's just like
she's sitting there in her mansion like
not for much longer not if candice owens
has anything to do with it i love cancer
okay um
so what'd you think of this video
have you seen it before
i've seen parts of it i haven't seen all
of it um
i think
the emotional
arguments
when it comes to racism
always will get shot down if you don't
bring up statistics or something that is
et cetera if you start to say you're a
mean white woman do you know what i mean
i always do it's just like okay because
now you're just attacking the person and
not dealing with the argument yeah so
i think i think they both made good
points i don't think it was a big enough
segment for me to get enough of what
jordan peterson had to say because i
think michael dyson definitely knows how
to speak he just kept going he
definitely knows how to speak so um
yeah it was cool like i said i think
i think these debates need to happen as
much as they like piss people off yeah
um
i think the more you speak about stuff
is the more you
i'm sorry the more you try to understand
the person's side
it's probably the place where you get to
like
that great area
which speaking of which guys we are
launching a new show going to the new
show the grey area
i wonder i wonder why i wonder i don't
know why would it be great i can't think
of a single reason it's just what two
colors make great it's a cool color i
don't know
um but it's gonna be tuesday at um 9 p.m
and yeah you guys should tune in and
watch it live
um i liked the video i thought it was a
good video i think
i'm i'm a die-hard jordan peterson fan
yeah that is i'm like that is my number
one guy
so i'm always going to think he was
making points yeah he was making points
yeah i mean i like jordan peterson yeah
i do believe that
michael dyson is a little bit
he's a little bit wordy for no reason no
reason at all he just keeps going and
it's a little bit worse
he wants to sound smarter than what he
seems like an insecurity thing yeah
it doesn't mean to say he hasn't got
anything to say but i think
when you try to just be oh look i'm the
great you shout at grandstand
yeah yeah
yeah
okay guys
um thank you for watching don't forget
to subscribe to the channel like the
video
um also sign up for our memberships for
exclusive behind the scenes content and
subscribe to sarah's pages subscribe to
my pages
on instagram
on facebook which is i know it's like no
one uses anymore facebook i have a
facebook live wow sarah garvey on
facebook why are all right
um on the instagram on the twitter on
the tick tock which is good as well
because i see i'm also older now oh he's
he's he's hip now i'm old ending i've
got a tick tock now sorry i got your
tick tock so yeah subscribe to me now
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
and we will talk to you next time bye